[Applause]
hi gorgeous lady
oh my gosh you look amazing
right back at you it's been too long
drew it so
first of all before we get going i want
to congratulate you on
everything and what a great great show
yeah i'm just loving every minute of it
and you never cease to amaze me
good for you girl thank you and i've
wanted to collaborate with you
for as long as i can remember i've been
such
a fan of yours for so long and i think
your
body of work is just so extraordinary
and um you know whether it's
when we were falling in love with you
from zorro and entrapment
you know all the way to your academy
award which
by the way i had a curious question um
that some of the producers didn't
necessarily want the bob for chicago
is that true yeah it it's
true and and so for me when i saw velma
kelly
i i saw that blunt louise brooks look
and and also it's period you know as an
actor you know the period they didn't
have they didn't have
beach waves you know in 1930s chicago
and i won that i won that battle you
know as you
as you get older it's like one of the
things i say to my daughter because you
can never put
an old head on young shoulders is like
pick your battles you know just pick
your battles sometimes you gotta let
things go
other times you've got to stand by your
guns and just go
no this is this is important and i did
anyway um that kind of image was was
always part of my
vision for the character well and as you
wield your academy award
it's nice to know that those choices
matter
and you talked about your daughter and
um you know it's it's mother's day is
around the corner
and i just was so excited your
daughter's
18 now um and
about to go off to college right
yeah there she is um i mean
i know it's it's just it's just
it's always soaps up because both my
michael and i are just about to become
empty nesters
yes exactly and that word for me that
term was like so cold it was like it was
like what do you mean empty next they're
not going anywhere they're just going
off to school
but the idea is you know when i really
sit down and think about it it gives me
joy to be an
empty nester because i see what both
michael have done
and look i'm not bragging you never know
as a parent
what you're going to get yeah that's the
best laid plans
whatever it's just to two people come
together and that they and there's a
creation and
and then you guide them and and i i had
a mother who you know as you said
mother's day around the corner
um was a wonderful blueprint of what a
mother should be
you know strict but gave good man you
know for her it was manners
um and just a disciplinarian but kind
she let she gave us a long long long
leash
but we never ever made that tort or you
know
try to get off the leash and do our own
thing it was this is where the leash is
and you can go and have fun and do and
explore and become
and and but you know these are the these
are the
the parameters and and with my children
i tried to instill those
those um qualities the best i could
and the both michael and i
you know when we when we the best best
joy we have is when we get complimented
about our kids behavior and their
manners and how
they're just good true grounded kids
and so um they're they've turned out
great
and so now that that term empty nest
i look at michael and go hey remember me
now we go back to knowing we've done our
bed
and and we can enjoy their journey
be there for them for support um
tell them if the leash is you know at
least you need to drain it in a bit
but just be there and and let them enjoy
this time
they love their lust for learning is
just
insatiable and so that gives me joy
and their love of the craft of acting
is so strong that even
when michael their brains they want to
they're doing politics and history in
school but their passion is acting and
they've never done anything professional
but they would like to go into acting
and
you know you come from a family where
your name is
yeah and very much like michael
very similar stories where you both had
to be the kids of
i never had that i was like audition i
mean they don't want me i'll just queue
up around the corner and go back and
stand in line again but my kids michael
has said to them about what it's like to
be the daughter of
in the same industry which is i guess
similar if you're in business
in business your kids have you know it's
not an easy way in
in fact one has to prove oneself more
yes absolutely no even with that
deterrent my kids are like that sorry
can't we still want to do it so and i've
had a wonderful wonderful life being an
actor
and if they get half the joy that i've
had all i want my kids to be is happy
and healthy
everything else is a bonus right well i
love that you've
let them be kids you let them figure out
what they wanted for themselves
uh rather than telling them and i really
respect the way that you
and your wonderful husband um
gives you a big kiss by the way oh my
god i love him so
much i can't even believe it and by the
way um
i heard that he notices when you do
something different or you wear
something different
and he compliments you on it and you
said smart guy
and i thought yeah that is a smart okay
but no i'm not gonna i know i'm not
gonna it's not gonna be
you know michael can't do any wrong you
know what he doesn't do which
happened like i've never let him it's
happened
i'd let it go but it happened a few
times
is that he doesn't tell me if i got
something caught in my tooth oh yeah no
you have to do that that's like a
girlfriend thing
not her girlfriend thing but if you
remember taking my man for 20 years
he's got to tell you that so now he's
like now
he says to me come here come here come
here and say what what what what like
i've done like a naughty school called
what have i done well what do you what
he goes let me check your teeth oh you
you broke him for all the right reasons
well men are like little puppies you
gotta train them i don't know what to
say
they uh they they always could use a
blueprint themselves look they're not
born with crystal balls
and you guys have been married for 20
years
yeah 21 years in november 20 years yeah
and you have the same birthday
and we have the same birthday yes yes
yes i know it's bizarre
and it's so funny because it's 20 years
i mean it's a reason why we're together
there's so many things that connect us
to this to connect us
but um oh look at that that's our
wedding day look at that
it was one of the most amazing days of
my life but yeah 20
20 years but this even our handwriting
is very similar
you know we can come from two different
parts of the world or to
two different types of families cultures
and um age 25 years different
um but who's counting i don't care i
don't think age matters
numbers don't mean anything it's the
soul
and the heart and the life experience
and none of that has to do with numbers
no i'm with you on that but there's um
there's something um you know that
really does connect it's like
handwriting it's like we go to
restaurants and if we would well
you know before colgate we used to go to
restaurants and if we were on a big long
kind of family you know or friends
dinner it could be 20 people 24 people
i'd be i always like we always like to
mix each other you know we never like to
sit next to each other when we go for
dinner parties
do you want to talk to other people and
and so if michael's down the other table
down one end and i'm done the other you
can guarantee we're ordering the same
um appetizer main course in dessert
it sounds like made for each other